The earliest event in the Chucky
timeline is September 1866 when
the Hackensack Mayor’s House is built.
And then we don’t know anything
that happened for another 93 years until
the birth of Charles Lee Ray on March 12th,
1959. We don’t see Chucky’s date of birth
anywhere so how do I know it occurs in 1959?
To begin, this newspaper article states his
parents were killed on his 7th birthday.
This is confusing, because another article
states Ray Parents Slain, 8-year-old Charles
Orphaned. That means one of these articles has
to be wrong. If we count the candles on his cake
there are seven of them, and on the radio we
hear the killer is on the loose that same day.
Let’s make an excuse for the filmmakers and just
say this article came out a year after the killing
took place. The Ray parents WERE slain. The now
8 year old Charles was orphaned. If we saw more
of this text it would be something along the lines
of: “Police were called last night to 987 Sherwood
Lane only to discover what must have been a
shocking display of murder in the mid-century
modern home. That’s what the papers said one
year ago.” It’s not unheard of for journalists
to do a follow up story on the anniversary
of an event, so let’s just go with that.
This headline, from March 12th,
1965 mentions a Gruesome Double-Homicide.
This is most likely Charles’s parents,
so let’s just tentatively put 1965 down as the
year that Charles turns from 6 years old to 7.
The other date we can fill in is in 1972, as
shown by the title text here, when Charles was
14 years old, as shown by the credits of
that episode. It doesn’t say if this scene
takes place before or after his birthday that
year, but it must be after. So Charles started
the year as 13 year old. We know he didn’t start
the year as a 14 year old and turn 15 that year,
because in order for that to be possible,
his seventh birthday would have been in 1964.
In th is shot in episode 1, it clearly shows
Charles and his mom both alive in 1965. That
means his parents must have been killed on
his 7th birthday sometime after that in 1965.
So we can fill in that he was 13 to begin the
year in 1972, and the rest of the calendar
fills out cleanly, which leaves us with March
12th, 1959 as the year that Charles was born.
If you want to know the date of
everything else in the franchise,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
It appears to be that same year, 1972, when
Charles leaves the Wayward Boys Home. The next
known event is the birth of Andy Barclay on Nov
9th 1982. How do I know this? In Child’s Play 1,
we see Charles get killed in the early hours
of the morning, transfer his soul into Chucky,
and Chucky is given to Andy on his sixth
birthday. So Charles’ death day is the
same day as Andy’s birthday. In Bride
of Chucky and in Season 1 Episode 3,
we see that Charles died on November
9th, 1988. Subtract the 6 years of Andy’s
life before meeting Chucky and you have
Andy’s date of birth: November 9th 1982.
And yes, I’m aware of this file in Child’s
Play 2 that lists Andy’s birthday as January 4,
1983, but remember, this is just the toy
company’s file on him. It was the 80s,
they didn’t have the internet, they probably
just had bad info. We can throw that out.
Then there’s the beginning of Charles’ crime
career in 1984, according to a newspaper seen in
Curse. This is assuming nobody ever found out that
he killed his Mom or the janitor at the orphanage.
This is probably the same year that he met Tiffany,
because we see them commit crimes together right away.
Chucky and Tiffany get their Pontiac in 1987,
and move to Chicago shortly after in 1988.
So then we have November 9th, 1988, the day that
Charles dies and transfers his soul into the doll,
which is also the day Nica is born, because we
see Charles go from his apartment with Tiffany
to the room he’s keeping the pregnant Sarah
captive in to the toy store where he’s shot.
And yes, I’m aware of this paper in Curse,
that claims Charles was killed the day
before December 27th 1988. We know that the
tombstones and other newspapers are correct,
however, and this article is not, because
there are no Christmas decorations seen
anywhere in the original Child’s Play. It was
just a typo, OK? A severe and continuous typo.
And yes, I’m aware of this chart in Cult,
that claims Nica was born in ‘87 rather
than ‘88. This also has to be a typo,
because we literally see Nica being born
and it leads right into Child’s Play.
So Child’s Play starts on November
9th, 1988, and takes place over a
few days. Eddie Caputo blows up on the
10th, Norris shoots Chucky on the 11th.
On December 29, 1988 Andy gives an interview in
a tabloid newspaper. Then there’s Child’s Play 2,
all we know is that it takes
place in October of 1990,
based on the fact that Andy is slightly older,
and this calendar where the first of the month
is on Monday. The only year in that vicinity
where October starts on a Monday is in 1990.
Onto Child’s Play 3, Chucky finds Andy’s file in
a computer, and it states his present age is 16
years old. If Andy turned 6 in November 1988, then
his 16th birthday is in November 1998. In Child’s
Play 3 we see snow on the ground but it looks
like it’s melting as if it’s early Spring in 1999.
In Bride of Chucky, Tiffany
reunites with Chucky and says,
– I know, it took me 10 years to find you.
– This
would be not long after the 10 year mark from
Chucky’s death, meaning that Bride of Chucky
probably takes place in Spring 1999 as well.
This checks out, because she would have found
out that Chucky was back shortly after he was
shredded in the fan in Child’s Play 3.
She went straight to retrieve the pieces.
There’s also a sticker on Jesse’s car in
Bride that says 12/98. Those stickers are
usually valid for 6 months, so yeah, it’s more
evidence that we’re in the first half of 1999.
There’s another time skip before Seed of Chucky.
The movie set scene takes place on March 18th,
2004, as seen on the date of
that day’s issue of Variety,
and the film takes place over a few days until the
21st. Then there’s an epilog scene 5 years later,
which is Glen and Glenda’s birthday
party. They were born on the final
night of the main story of Seed, the
21st, so this is now March 21st 2009.
We don’t actually see the date of Curse of Chucky
until the opening credits of the movie after:
Cult of Chucky, where we found out that the little
girl who survived, Alice, was found on January 8,
2013. It doesn’t look all that cold out
in Curse, but maybe it was a warm winter.
Nica was ruled insane in her trial a few months
later on April 7th, 2013. At some point after
that, Chucky finds out how to split his soul up
into multiple dolls and sends one to attack Andy,
which Andy captures and tries to use as
proof that Nica is not crazy on November
1st, 2013. He’s not successful, but he
publishes the video online that same day.
– Wait a minute, there’s two of them?
– Yes, there are multiple Chuckys already. So
another one of them is sent to attack Andy at his
apartment. This is the epilogue of Curse - stated
to be 6 months after Nica’s trial. That puts it
in late October or early November. Actually, we
know it’s early November, because of this line.
– Yeah, I’m definitely coming
for my birthday tomorrow.
Which means the date is November
8th, 2013, the day before Andy’s
25th birthday. The next action would
go down almost four years after this.
(cinematic impact)
(eerie drone)
Nearly four years go by before
the main events of Cult of Chucky.
– [Dr. Foley] In the past four years you’ve had to
accept some hard truths about yourself.
– Chucky starts taking victims at
the asylum on January 24th, 2017,
because we see the date listed on this Perez
Hilton article. Some of the top related stories
during articles in Cult are about Obamacare and the
Trump Wall, so January 2017 seems accurate,
since this was not long before Obama’s term
as US president ended and Trump’s term began.
Finally that brings us to Chucky Season 1.
Some people have suggested that this takes
place right after Cult of Chucky, in 2017,
however, it actually takes place in 2021,
and I have plenty of proof. My only note is
that, like many TV shows made in the 20s,
this seems to take place in a world where
COVID-19 never happened. Please take me there.
Chucky first re-emerges in Hackensack in
Mid-March, which we can see is where the murder
rate spikes on this graph. This has gotta be March
2021, because Devon says
– [Devon] in the past year alone,
our murder rate has spiked 25%.
– But the
series doesn’t start until October 18th,
a date we can derive from the fact that
Lucas Wheeler’s headstone lists his death
as October 19th 2021, and we first meet him one day before that.
It’s stated that
Jake misses a week of school after this.
In episode 2, a title card says
Hackensack Present Day. The episode
takes place on Halloween, and indeed it
did come out on the week of Halloween in 2021.
That means episode 3, which would be
the day after, is set on November 1st.
The song that they listen to at Lexi’s
silent disco party came out in 2020,
so it can’t still be 2017.
The song wasn’t out yet.
Episode 4 looks like it is the next
morning: November 2nd. In this one,
Chucky refers to Lexi as a Karen on training
wheels. Even though COVID didn’t happen in
this universe, I’m still gonna assume that
the Karens made themselves known in 2020.
The confusion come about in Episode
5. Nica, after being possessed by
the soul of Charles Lee Ray, regains
control of her body and asks his guy
for the date. He tells her it’s November
8th, and she says...
– It’s been 2 weeks.
– This led some people to believe that
Chucky Season 1 takes place in 2017,
2 weeks after Cult of Chucky. However, that
doesn’t make sense. November does not take
place 2 weeks after January. What most
likely happened, is that Nica is
basically asleep whenever Chucky is in control
of her body. She might have temporarily gotten
control back in October 2017, or October 2018,
19, or 20, it doesn’t really matter. And then
Chucky was in control for one or more years after
that. When Nica regained control on November 8th
2021, she assumed that only 2 weeks had
passed when it had actually been years.
If you need any more proof that it’s 2021,
look at this conversation that Jake
and Devon have about horror movies.
– [Devon] Favorite final girl?
– [Jake] Laurie Strode! Hands down.
– Jamie Lee’s gonna
win the Saturn this year.
– Dude she’s gonna win
an Oscar, she’s magnificent.
– They must be talking about
Halloween Kills from 2021,
because Jamie Lee Curtis was
not in any movies in 2017.
The rest of the series just takes place in
mid-November. We don’t know the exact date,
but in Episode 6, there’s an
intro scene, which is the first
time we see Andy Barclay in the show. It
appears to happen right after Episode 5,
which would mean that Andy is reintroduced
on his birthday again, which is kind of fun.
The last thing to figure out is how
long Andy was in captivity after Cult.
– [Devon] I Googled Andy Barclay and got an article
from 2 weeks ago. Violent patient escapes
Harrogate Psychiatric Hospital. Manhunt underway.
That would mean that Andy didn’t escape until
October 25th, 2021. So he was actually in
Harrogate for almost 5 years. However,
in the same episode, Jake says this.
– I got a call from Rhode Island about
a month ago. It must be Andy Barclay.
– We saw that phone call in episode 1,
meaning that it happened on October 19th,
six days before Andy supposedly escaped.
Andy is a pretty crafty guy. And the
hospital was left very short staffed
after the events of Cult. I think what
happened here was Andy escaped a while ago.
They just didn’t realize he escaped until much
later. He might have escaped the previous winter,
because the epilogue of Cult shows Kyle, in
the winter, putting away the Chucky head at
Andy’s request. We can assume it took some time
for Andy and Kyle to meet up again after that.
I don’t know how Andy pulled off
this escape without them realizing,
but he probably tricked one of the new
incoming patients into pretending to be him
and took advantage of a new staff member
that didn’t know names and faces yet.
So I just wanted to make this video to clarify
my current views on the Chucky timeline before
I start making any more Chucky Horror History
episodes, so I can focus more on the character
analysis when I do make those. I am getting
eye surgery soon, that’s why I’m wearing
glasses lately. I’m gonna try not to miss
a week, but if I do, that’s probably why.
If this ends up being my last video ever,
then I guess I got Final Destination 5’d.
But for the event that doesn’t happen, please
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell and set
it to all notifications,
and I’ll see you in the next
one assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)